[Musik]
die afg im bundestag die kanzlerin
erheblich geschwächt die spd nicht
länger volkspartei die ränder gestärkt
und die mittige ohrfeigt der wähler hat
serviert einen neuen bundestag ein
ergebnis mit ansage alles andere als
überraschend
das war bieten zäsur für deutschland
geht die zuschauer der titel der phoenix
runde heute abend herzlich willkommen
bei uns meine gäste christian hausmann
ist hier stellvertretende leiterin des
hauptstadtstudios des
nachrichtenmagazins der spiegel
roland tichy journalist und publizist
herausgeber des meinungsmacher zinstiefs
einblick und vorsitzender der ludwig
erhard stiftung professor werner patzelt
politikwissenschaftler an der
technischen universität in dresden und
professor thomas kliche politik
psychologe an der hochschule
magdeburg-stendal so hoffmann
das heißt ja so schön die politiker
haben das volk das sie verdienen und das
volk hat die politiker die jetzt
verdient hat die zurückliegende
bundestagswahl die richtigkeit dieser
beiden sätze wieder auf das
vortrefflichste bestätigt ja dass wenn
man daran glauben will dann würde ich
das schon sagen ich finde übrigens dass
es doch etwas überraschend war dieses
ergebnis haben wir in der einleitung
gesagt gar keine überraschung für mich
gab es eigentlich zwei ergebnisse die
doch nicht ganz so warm wie ich sie
erwartet hätte das eine war das sehr
schwache abschneiden der union man ja
klar wenn wir davon ausgegangen das ist
auf keinen fall möglich sein würde ein
sehr gutes ergebnis sowohl oder ein
gutes aber dass am ende eine 32 da steht
also das schlechteste ergebnis in der
bundesrepublikanischen geschichte oder
seit 49
das war dann doch weniger als ich
erwartet hätte und das zweite war das
doch relativ gute abschneiden der grünen
die einen sehr schwachen wahlkampf
geführt hatten sind
und einige partei sind dass sie am ende
ihr ergebnis sogar noch leicht
verbessern konnten das war eigentlich
zwei überraschenden momente in der hätte
ich aus früheren auftritten von ihnen
dafür nichts und da habe ich noch in
erinnerung dass sie kein glühender
anhänger von angela merkel sind das
jetzt weil sie schlecht zwölf jahre
knochenarbeit mir nicht nur mit
politischen gegnern sondern mit
renitenten parteifreunden im inland und
renitenten partnern im ausland liege
hinter ihr hat die kanzlerin dieses
ergebnis verdient also wenn sie so
argumentieren hätte helmut schmidt nicht
aufhören dürfen kontodaten sowieso nicht
dann hätte gerhard schröder der könnte
jetzt noch kanzler seien die frauen
wechseln der kanzler bleibt also
dankbarkeit ist keine kategorie der
politik sondern das wesen der demokratie
ist das unblutige auswechslung von
führungseliten ich bin ohnehin der
meinung das würde sogar automatisieren
sollte was zwei legislaturperioden genug
sind weil die politik hier so einen
eigenen mechanismus hat nämlich die
entfremdung des politikers von der
realen welt und auch die eigene
überhöhung das hat überhaupt nichts mit
angela merkel zu tun sondern es konnte
man und kann man eigentlich bei jedem
der beobachten barack obama und hillary
clinton können auch nicht glauben dass
ihre zeit einfach abgelaufen ist also
das ist irgendwie diese einsamkeit an
der spitze dieses nicht loslassen können
war auch bei helmut kohl so und das
beobachtet man hat jetzt auch bei angela
merkel das ist ich kann nicht vorstellen
kann dass das land auch ohne sie weiter
existieren kann
insofern würde ich hier auch für mehr
ruhe plädieren der wechsel gehört zur
demokratie das ist wunderbar so es muss
jetzt mal was frisches her ist muss auch
ein generationswechsel her dass die spd
ist dabei alles nicht zu überzeugen
aber vielleicht passiert ja noch was
aber zu glauben dass die cdu und auch
die csu so weitermacht als wäre nichts
geschehen jedes jahr ist erwiesen und
seehofer ist immer
ministerpräsident das kann es ja nicht
sein wir passen ist die afd
der einzug der elfte in den bundestag
mit fast 13 das ist ein wahlerfolg ist
das sozusagen die rache des kleinen
mannes
das ist eine möglichkeit das
auszudrücken die andere möglichkeit wäre
dass ich die strafe dafür dass die cdu
es partout nicht wollte weiterhin den
rechten flügel an sich zu binden
eine parteien nicht nur den mitte zu
sein sondern eine partei auch für jene
zu sein die sich nun einmal nicht als
mutig oder gar als links empfinden
sondern als rechts und dieser verzicht
darauf dass alte erfolgsgeheimnisse
union wirklichkeit bleiben zu lassen
nämlich von der mitte bis an den rechten
rand alles einzuholen was irgendwie
vernünftig ist oder vernünftig in eine
runde politik einzubauen ist der
verzicht darauf ist irrt worden durch
diese erhebliche klatsche der in sachsen
noch wesentlich größer waren als auf
bundesebene wo sie ja zur stärksten
partei geworden ist der kirche
die unzufriedenheit ist groß im land das
zeigen alle wahlanalysen weniger mit der
eigenen situation sondern mit dem gefühl
dass vieles nicht funktioniert dass der
gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt nicht so
funktioniert dass man auch angst vor der
zukunft hat
das ist ja interessant in einem land es
gibt kaum ein land das in europa das
politisch wirtschaftlich sozial so
stabil ist wie deutschland woher kommt
das daher geht es überhaupt nicht mehr
um unzufriedenheit da geht es um eine
historische erfahrung den einschnitt von
2015 wo wir erlebt haben und da sind die
flüchtlinge hier im grunde nur ein
beispielhaftes thema das unsere
regierung nicht mehr im stande ist
internationale krisen abzuwehren oder zu
steuern dass wir im grunde keine
verlässlichen internationalen oder auch
nationalen mechanismen haben um
dauerhaft frieden und wohlstand
sicherzustellen dass die krisenhaft ich
kite die wir mit den banken erlebt haben
jetzt auch über greift auf
internationale sehen und wenn man jetzt
hoch rechnet dass die polkappen
schmelzen dann auch eben bangladesch
verschwindet oder ähnliches dass solche
dinge sicher wiederholen werden
und jetzt stehen alle parteien die sich
15 jahre verzweifelt entpolitisiert
haben um sich in der mitte irgendwie um
ein paar kleine punkte zu kloppen da und
wissen nicht genau wohin und deshalb ist
das kein zufall dass die
flüchtlingsfrage auch so zuletzt in den
mittelpunkt gerückt das war sein
exemplarisch thema ist denn wir haben
eigentlich nur drei lösungsangebote das
eine ist nicht vorhanden
das zweite ist geschwächt und das dritte
ist reingekommen aber eigentlich kein
lösungsangebot was ist das erste das ist
was angela merkel gemacht hat verdient
oder nicht sie steht dafür man bastelt
weiter man arbeitet pragmatisch ohne
großen entwurf an der reparatur der
verhältnisse und versucht den leuten
klar zu machen das ist ungefähr meine
verlässlichkeit ich bin integer ich bin
sachkundig ich bin pragmatisch ich habe
keine idee was da noch kommen wird aber
ich versuche damit umzugehen
ja also ein im kern sozusagen
konservatives programm
die zweite möglichkeit ist die afd die
afg sagt alles fremde raus wir sind
unter uns wir sind die besten geld für
uns geld nur für die deutschland haben
wir keine probleme
das ist ja auch im grunde komplett exit
also eine neue internationale de und die
dritte möglichkeit hat sich im grunde
mit dem zweiten historischen versagen
der spd in diesem wahlkampf
verabschiedet die spd als größte partei
auf der linken mitte hätte die aufgabe
gehabt wenn wir den über alternativen
reden so was wie die grünen und die
linken vor einer handlungsfähigen
plattform zusammenzubringen um einen
entwurf einer solidarischen
zukunftsfähigen gesellschaft zu
entwickeln
das ist vielleicht immer noch ihre
historische mission soweit sie
demokratischen sozialismus nicht
eigentlich aufgegeben hat mit dem
personal und der arten miteinander
umzugehen
aber da fehlt was zeichnet sich irgendwo
fest sein
es ist doch nicht so dass die
flüchtlingskrise irgendwie eine
naturgewalt ist über die wir die
regierung hereingebrochen ist
es war ein fehler der regierung so zu
handeln wie sie 2015 gehandelt hat und
dafür ist sie abgestraft worden
es ist ein fehler der bundesregierung
dass sie die behandlung der
flüchtlingskrise nach wie vor die lato
risch betreibt dass sie keine
energischen maßnahmen für das richtige
was es heißt erkannt hat betreibt ist
auch ein fehler weil die große koalition
in sich zerstritten war und der eine
oder andere richtige weg den die cdu
hätte beschreiten wollen von der spd
blockiert wurde
das seien dinge ich glaube sie stellen
regierende ganz generell als opfer
widriger umstände hin es ist doch ein
käse politik kann man gestalten kann man
auch heute noch gestalten und mit denen
pohl karten haben wir morgen gerade kein
problem sondern haben die
flüchtlingskrise aber das ist so ist
dass die flüchtlingskrise letztlich ein
vehikel war diese unzufriedenheit die
entfremdung mit der politik das gefühl
da funktioniert kommunikation nicht mehr
diese ganz tief sitzenden ängste wie sie
gesagt haben finanzkrise ist ja alles
letztlich ein teil der globalisierung
die den die menschen beunruhigt das ist
eigentlich die tiefere ursache und die
flüchtlingskrise hat das nur nochmal
zusammengefasst zugespitzt und ist
michael um diese ängste auch zum aus
dass der wahlkampf vor allem in der
endphase wieder von der flüchtlingskrise
beherrscht worden ist jetzt die ganzen
erklärungsmuster sagt man das liegt vor
allen dingen an der flüchtlingskrise
also zum beispiel das abschneiden der
union
die flüchtlingskrise hat ja eigentlich
in den letzten monaten keine so große
rolle mehr real gespielt liefen fünf
toten sind faktisch dicht gemacht worden
wieso ist das immer noch so hoch
gekommen als würde man jetzt im herbst
des jahres 2015 sein
ja weil ihr kein ende des migrations
drucks auf europa absehbar ist und weil
er bis vor kurzem noch die aussage
dieser es lässt sich ohnehin die
mittelmeer überquerung nicht verhindern
und weil die aussage die war das ist
auch gar nicht in ordnung den
migrationsdruck auf europa anders als
dadurch dass man plötzlich nach so
vielen jahrzehnten von entwicklungshilfe
afrika so weit entwickelt dass überall
stabilität ist das hat ja keiner
geglaubt jeder wusste dass das
aufschieben der ausflüchte sind und es
hat schon die bevölkerung gemerkt dass
das thema das ihr mit am dringendsten
auf den nägeln brennt nämlich eben die
flüchtlingskrise und die anschließenden
integrationsprobleme dass das von
sämtlichen politischen parteien mit
ausnahme der afd
kunstvoll beschrieben wird das grüne und
linke und spd beschwiegen haben das ist
nicht verwunderlich weil ihr denen die
richtung welche die kanzlerin durch
entscheiden oder nicht entscheiden
eingeschlagen hat
zustimmen schien nur eben nicht
entschlossen genug weit genug
beschritten wurde die cdu das
beschwiegen weil eben hier führungs
fehler unterlaufen sind und die csu hat
irgendwann ihren widerstand aufgegeben
um der geschlossenheit im wahlkampf
inhaber und das eben funktioniert nicht
das ist wie ein zahn die entzündet ist
man kann den zahnschmelz versuchen zu
unterdrücken aber irgendwann alter das
ding eben doch also der entschuldigung
dafür dass vielleicht gleich gleich dazu
anfügen
wenn das jetzt die ursachen sind die
reaktion der politiker jetzt auf dieses
wahlergebnis also jetzt außerhalb der
afg haben die da verstanden haben die
das so antizipiert so aufgefasst dass
sie da wirklich fehler gemacht haben
also bei der kanzlerin kann ich das
überhaupt nicht erkennen ihre reaktion
war ganz klar wir haben alles richtig
gemacht ist doch eigentlich ganz gut
gelaufen
da sehe ich jedenfalls in der
kommunikation nach außen genau wie
vorher überhaupt keine veränderung ich
würde auch gern eins anfügen ich glaube
eben ein teil des problems ist dass die
union ja zwar ganz klar ihren
politischen kurs geändert hat die
kanzlerin sich aber geweigert hat das
sprechen darüber zu verändern und
anzupassen und dadurch und die leute
haben diese diskrepanz dieses
auseinanderklaffen gespürt zum einen und
zum anderen ist die grundsätzliche frage
wie wollen wir mit dieser migration
umgehen wie viele menschen und da muss
man glaube ich nicht unbedingt über eine
zahl reden sondern man muss über die
prinzipien unseres asylrechts reden wie
viele menschen wollen wir aufnehmen wie
können wir mit dieser migration umgehen
und diese ganz grundsätzliche wahnsinnig
schwierige und sehr strittige frage
haben wir gar nicht wirklich diskutiert
in der gesellschaft und ich glaube auch
das spüren die leute und deshalb denken
sie die kanzlerin sagt zwar so etwas
sollten nie wieder vorkommen
aber wie kann sie das denn bei uns aber
lieber in unterschiedlichen welten und
wahrnehmen sie reden aneinander vorbei
sie finden keine gemeinsame sprache
sie haben auch eine ganz andere
wahrnehmung es ebene politik und und
wähler
das halte ich für quatsch ich weiß ja
dass ist aber dass das ist ja da sind ja
dieses verbreitete vorurteil mit dass
politiker so weltfremd sind wenn ich
irgend jemanden kennen der mit ganz
unterschiedlichen menschen redet an
ihrem arbeitsplatz auf ihrer arbeit der
ständig sich auf neue menschen
einstellen muss er ständig geschichten
aus den seltsamsten ecken der
gesellschaft hat dann sind das politiker
neben sozialarbeitern und polizisten
sind das wahrscheinlich diejenigen den
breitesten horizont haben weil sie
ständig in ihrem wahlkreis mit
irgendjemandem irgendetwas zu tun haben
vom kaninchenzüchterverein über was weiß
ich wie ich glaube dass das wir wenn wir
über über angela merkel reden hier ein
strategisches dilemma der also
psychologische sprung verhinderungs
kommunikation sehen sie steht ja für
kontinuität weitermachen alles im griff
haben berechenbar sein und dann trifft
sie an einer stelle eine humanitär und
politisch gut begründbare nicht falsche
richtige entscheidung ich finde da hat
sie gute gründe werden nie diskutiert
haben weil nicht darüber diskutiert
worden ist zwar ein falsche gründe
überlegung sind sondern inzwischen
verstanden dass die anderer meinung sind
ich versuche dann auch und uns sie
möchte das jetzt umsetzen und sie hat
nicht wahnsinnig viel wirklich tiefe
entscheidungen ihrer in ihrer laufbahn
getroffen die also eine weiche gestellt
hat und die bankenrettung war so einer
da hat sie gezeigt dass das system auch
sehr schnell im stande ist tatsächlich
stark zu handeln und was auf die beine
zu stellen
deshalb ist es ganz sicher richtig
politiker nicht als opfer aufzufassen
das war auch nicht die idee trotzdem
stehen unsere ordnungen
wirtschaftsordnung gesellschaftsordnung
internationale ordnung inzwischen vor
herausforderungen die wir national kaum
noch lösen können das hat er die neue
diskussion über europäische
regulatorien haben und die wird uns
begleiten
und da wird sich auch zeigen dass
einzelne politiker nicht mehr so mit
diesem heroischen wir stellen um
weiterkommen
das problem dass sich nämlich hier
abzeichnet ist dass da ein neues
politikverständnis auftritt auf dem auch
die afg soft das politikverständnis dass
sie haben das ist auch dass auf dem bfd
surft nämlich so ein symbiotisches der
politiker ist da haben sie mir jetzt
center haben hier ich hab sie jetzt ich
will jetzt ihre klischees natürlich
voraus bleiben ahnungslos ist in ein
wunderbarer euro fest und mit vor ort
sagen sie vielleicht doch mit einem satz
war sie mit dem bio tischbein und dann
ist da ja ich versuche mich nicht wieder
unterbricht
ich kann man sie in einem satz sagen die
vorstellung wir sind eine gruppe wir
spüren uns wir haben einen führer der
das spürt was wir wollen der das
richtige tut der das auch macht die afg
nennt das volk und deshalb ist für sie
auch ganz natürlich dass sie sich als
vertreter des volkes erlebt und aus
dieser führer auch ganz
selbstverständlich die welt so richten
kann wie die gruppe das spürt das ist
eine eine forschung von politik auf der
gefühlsebene politiker sind eingebunden
an eine fülle von kompromiss gesetzes
und handlungssträngen angefangen beim
geld so diese liga wohl fühlen sich nur
1101 einstellung gefühlige politik zu
unterstellen ist völliger uns aber man
ist auch nichts neues ich würde auch
nicht sagen dass die cdu keine gefühls
politik macht ich würde anknüpfen
bei der analyse von vor hoffmann ja was
sie beschrieben haben ist die blindheit
der lange regierenden und ja natürlich
gibt es da eine gewisse distanz
und ja natürlich ist angela merkel eine
situation reingestolpert die sie eben
nicht mal bespricht und ist doch gar
keine frage übrigens von schuld und
fehler und die leute haben das gefühl
dieser fehler muss korrigiert werden
und wissen sie was an ihrer analyse so
ein bisschen komisch ist
sie nennen da immer die afd nehmen sie
doch die fdp wir reden hier die ganze
zeit über die afd wir haben eine zweite
partei die mit 10,6 prozent auch
immerhin den vierten platz besetzt
und die bisherigen nicht vorhandene
opposition linke und grüne werden auf
platz fünf und sechs verschoben das
heißt wir haben hier ja auch eine zweite
partei sehr liberal und bürgerlich sich
abgrenzt von der bundesregierung und das
wollen wir so nicht in der union
profitiert hat und ja natürlich wir mit
einem neuen angebot in die politik geht
der profitiert und ich glaube ich schon
dass da etwas passiert ist weil wenn ich
von spd und cdu gehört habe
da waren immer wahnsinnig viele menschen
weltweit wichtig aber nicht die
kernklientel dieser parteien und ich
glaube schon das ist eine aufgabe von
parteien ist interessen auch zu
vertreten
und deswegen hat ja die afg und jetzt
komme ich zur afg in einer stadt wie
duisburg marxloh mit einem
ausländeranteil von über 50 prozent 30
prozent der stimmen geholt weil die
menschen die nicht so wohlhabend sind um
in berlin-mitte leben zu können und die
nicht ihre kinder auf privatschulen
schicken können und die nicht eigenen
immobilien besitzen sondern auf mieter
arbeitsplatz schule angewiesen sind um
haben diese menschen vielfach eben
andere parteien gewählt und die spd im
regen stehen lassen das heißt hier
glaube ich ist schon etwas passiert dass
man ein bisschen übersehen hat dass es
in diesem land menschen mit wirklichen
sozialen problemen gibt und nicht mit
einer abstrakten gerechtigkeitsdebatte
die an der konkreten lebenswirklichkeit
der menschen nicht mehr anknüpft das ist
das drama der lange regierten da muss
man übrigens gar nicht böse sein da muss
man sagen das war's halt das spiel gut
das war jetzt auch der versuch einer
erklärung ich zu diesem wahlergebnis
gekommen ist gucken wir mal in die
zukunft es wird jetzt kommt die afg
würde im bundestag ist eine mischung aus
kasperletheater und plattform für
demagogie aufbauen
hier die äußerung von alexander gauland
wir werden sie jagen im bundestag die
die regierung und die anderen parteien
muss das wirklich zu kommen ist das fast
zwanghaft dass es so kommt es muss nicht
zu kommen aber die wahrheit ist wohl
dass es in der afg mindestens zwei
linien gibt eine linie deren kapitänen
soeben abgegangen ist hatte den plan die
afg zu einer normalen staatstragenden
parteien rechnen für den namen und diese
linie hat sich jetzt nicht durchgesetzt
gegen die anderen welche die af der
seine sammlungsbewegung versteht eine
sammlungsbewegung aller die recht stehen
wir sind zum rechten rand und allmählich
mit der bemerkung zu versehen
bis dorthin wo einem vor gar nichts mehr
graust und diesen haufen zusammen zu
fügen
das etwas draus wird was
parlamentarische sacharbeit machen kann
das fragen an die regierung formulieren
kann bei deren antworten die regierung
sich eine blöße vielleicht gibt die man
politisch ausnutzen kann
das ist eine herkulesaufgabe ob die dem
guten gauland gelingt das steht offen er
zwar heute ausgegeben die zeit für
wahlkampfrede ist vorbei es ist die zeit
für parlamentarische rede
und die sei etwas anderes womit er
völlig recht hat aber ob seine ganzen
bataillone und die dortigen wortführer
sich daran halten das ist eine offene
frage
und folglich ist da überhaupt nichts
vorgezeichnet die am nächsten liegende
parallele sind die grünen sie kommen
herein als eine anti parteien partei als
eine partei die von sich den eindruck
hat sie erfindet das politische system
neu macht alles anders und im laufe der
jahre ist sie einfach von der funktions
logik unseres systems so beeindruckt
worden um das wort zurecht geschliffen
wurden zu vermeiden
das ist eine ganz normale stadtpartei
einfach mit der eigenen farbe ist wie
sieht das update eine gute einen guten
brauch bei uns personen in neuen ämtern
eine sogenannte 100 tage schonfrist zu
geben jedenfalls wird das ja immer
wieder abgehoben
sollte man das bei der alv die fraktion
auch tun so sagen jetzt ihr wollt euch
nach den aussagen als
fraktionsvorsitzenden parlamentarisch
dem parlamentarischen
sicher sagen priental braucht
zumindestens einfügen
und dann warten wir mal ab wie er damit
umgeht ich finde das kann sich nicht auf
äußerungen der partei beziehen das kann
sich vielleicht auf der die
notwendigkeit sich an bestimmte abläufe
zu gewöhnen beziehen aber ganz bestimmt
nicht wenn solche reden wie von herrn
bauland am wahlabend vom stapel gelassen
sagte soll wahr zu sein noch nicht
parlamentsrede gewesen das war noch
wahlkampf gut ja dann wollen wir sehen
ob wir jetzt parlamentsrede kommt aber
da finde ich nicht dass mir dass wir da
100 tage das milde betrachtet ja die
frage ist ja war er dann das jetzt schon
quasi über die afg gerichtet wird bevor
der bundestag in der neuen form das
erste mal zusammen zusammengetreten ist
ja also ich sehe nicht dass über es wird
darüber dass gerichtet was bisher
passiert was wir sehen eine spaltung
oder jedenfalls eine abspaltung der
letztlich stärksten kandidatin mit dem
dieser stärkste wahlergebnis geholt hat
vom ersten tag an eine krisenhafte
situation und das muss man auch so
benennen wie es ist sehe ich nicht dass
warum man das nicht tun sollte die afg
gilt ja als ein sammelbecken von
enttäuschten wie auch immer wir können
ja auch umgekehrt fragen wie kann
eigentlich die afg enttäuschend zum
beispiel ihre anhänger die die sie
gewählt haben
ich glaube dass die ard auf dem weg der
provokation weitermachen wird weil das
für die gefühls politik die ein
wichtiges angebot an ihrer wähler ist
zentrales soweit ich das aus unseren
untersuchungen sehen vor allem mit
interviews weil die demoskopie zunehmend
und zuverlässig geworden wird hat die
afg viel große gruppen die
modernisierungsverlierer die hätte ich
hier angesprochen hat oder die leute die
angst haben vor abstieg die selber haben
sind die sich von anderen bedroht fühlen
sind ja nur ein kleiner teil die afg
wird ja nicht überproportional von
schlechter gebildeten oder sowas gewählt
sondern überproportional von männern mit
lagen männern im auch berufstätigen das
ist eine gruppe menschen die das gefühl
haben die wirtschaft und unsere
gesellschaftsordnung sorgt nicht für uns
eine zweite gruppe sind einfach
überzeugte rechtsextreme die von der npd
und den ganzen organisationen das ja
inzwischen sehr offenen agieren
rechtsextremen netzwerks darüber
geströmt sind mit denen die afg sehr
gute kameradschaft hält und für die dann
eben auch solche symbole politischen
signale sind wie die verharmlosung der
verbrechen der wehrmacht das ist einfach
das signal freunde wir sind blut von
eurem blut wir können nur nicht so reden
sonst hauen die medien auf uns herum
das muss man am köcheln halten die sind
auch bei der stange und die sind für die
organisation wichtig eine dritte gruppe
sind cdu erziehungs oder cdu enttäuschte
wähler also sehr konservative wähler die
entweder über die flüchtlingsfrage oder
über familienpolitische sachen zu der
idee gekommen sind da ist rechts
irgendetwas was mir fehlt da will ich
jetzt mal gucken dass sich die cdu
wieder ein bisschen in die richtige
richtung krieg um zur not eben erst mal
auf der l und eine vierte gruppe die
haben wir in ostdeutschland sehr stark
sind menschen die tief entfremdet sind
von gesellschaft politik überhaupt mich
hat das sehr erschreckt weil diese
entsprechenden einstellungen auch bis
sogar in amtsträger bereiche
reingegangen sind menschen die erlebt
haben als bürgermeister oder sogar ja ja
ja also ich will jetzt auf der
kommunalen ebene
auch auf der nationalen ebene will jetzt
die ämter nicht nennen weil einfach die
stichprobe ist das in jeder sofort
wusste wovon man redet oder von wem man
redet aber dieses gefühl ich kann
eigentlich in der gesellschaft nicht
viel steuern also sozusagen da hat hätte
hier recht man darf daraus keinen
opfermythos mal ich werde über waltz hat
keinen sinn es ist eigentlich nicht
gerecht es gibt keine gerechtigkeit in
der gesellschaft und die normen und
werte dir da herrschen haben mit mir und
meinem engagement darum werden nicht
viel zu tun ich ziemlich auf
freundeskreis und familie zurück das hat
natürlich viel mit ddr tradition und
erfahrung zu tun dass der staat etwas
bedrohliches ist mit der schwäche von
zivilgesellschaft da und enttäuschen die
afg kann enttäuschen eigentlich
niemanden von der rechtsextremen ecke
solange sie denen eine stimme gibt indem
sie das symbol politische duftmarke
gesetzt dass sie weitermachen die
provokationen ecke ist da sozusagen der
exponent sie kann eigentlich nicht
enttäuschen die cdu wähler denn die
werden sich die cdu angucken sind von
erzählt nicht einhalten die frage ist ja
sie haben jetzt noch sehr differenziert
werden
die afg wählte er das sympathisant ist
angela merkel hat ja gleich gesagt am
montag sie würde jetzt eine politik
machen um eben viele von diesen
enttäuschten zurückzugewinnen
wie ist denn das bei der afg wer ist
gehört er zum harten kern der nicht mehr
erreichbar ist und wie groß ist der
anteil der sogenannten protestwähler die
einfach den anderen parteien nicht nur
der cdu zeigen wollten wir sind nicht
mit dem zufrieden was ihr für uns tut
wir fühlen uns aus welchen gründen auch
immer man so schön sagt abgehängt nach
den zahlen die wir am sonntag am gehört
haben dürften wohl ungefähr 60 prozent
der fdp-wähler protestwähler gewesen
sein ob das schon fünf prozent mehr oder
weniger sind tut nichts zur sache und
der rest leute die von der afg
angesprochen sind in all den bereichen
die sie soeben benannt haben zurückholen
das ist ein guter vorsatz hätte nur
einmal die bundeskanzlerin
jene die jetzt bei der afg gelandet sind
nicht mit ihrer neujahrsansprache
2014/15 vergrault die falsche reaktion
auf kägi das zurückweisen von sorgen die
geäußert worden sind hatte die falsche
reaktion auf die afg vorgezeichnet
und nach dem was ich von der afg aus der
afd
von eiff dlan höhere und darüber lese
ist das ausmaß an erbitterung über das
politische system und seine exponenten
so groß das ausmaß der inneren
verhärtung so groß dass man umso mehr
abweisend agiert je mehr man umgarnt und
umworben werden nämlich ganz wesentlich
aus dem grund weil man sagt das meint
die ja nicht ernst denn ihren großen
fehler oder auch richtig aber vielleicht
nicht auf dauer richtig in großen fehler
gesteht sie ja nicht eins sie verändert
die politik aber gibt es nicht zu
wahrscheinlich ist das alles nur aus
taktischen gründen
und wenn sie jetzt am wahlabend erklärt
hat in zukunft will sie vielleicht doch
etwas mehr auf die sorgen der bürger
hören die probleme zur kenntnis nehmen
durch eine problem lösen de politik die
beschwernisse die auch von ihr gefühlt
wurden wären im wahlkampf verringern
ja das sagt doch ändert das sagte jetzt
nur unter dem druck des wahlergebnisses
erst wenn die als demnächst wahlen noch
mehr stimmen hat dann wird die den weg
frei machen für eine nachfolge das heißt
das so ist jetzt nicht mehr das
zurückgewinnen wird auch erst einen
nachfolger oder nachfolgerin angela
merkel gelingen
für sie wird es sehr schwer da
glaubwürdig eine kurve zu bekommen weil
ich glaube dass sie ist einfach zutiefst
überzeugt gewesen von diesem kurs oder
ist es vielleicht auch noch dass man
eben mit denen nicht spricht geht nicht
mit denen so und das ausgrenzen
letztlich auch tabuisieren der der
richtige weg ist ich glaube wir haben ja
wir haben ja das ist ja auch eine
erkenntnis dieser wahl dieser diese
unglaubliche spaltung zwischen ost und
westdeutschland gesehen das ist ja
richtig wie zwei länder im wahlverhalten
in bezug auf die grünen in bezug auf die
fdp und auf die afg sehr sehr stark und
die spd natürlich auch und das hat hat
merkel im wahlkampf sehr stark zu spüren
bekommen und das war ja höchst
symbolisch dieses sich gegenseitig über
schreien ja dieses wir wollen gehört
werden sozusagen zwar wurde der war dass
die lexika hau ab aber gemeint war
schaut uns an hör uns mal zu und sie hat
es letztlich mit dem mikrofon
überschrieben mit ihrem
reden die gar nicht darauf eingegangen
sind und ich glaube eben dass sie gerade
als jemand der aus ostdeutschland kommt
letztlich nie ein verständnis entwickelt
hat sie hat das abgelehnt sie hat sie
das ist sie einfach zutiefst fremd
menschen die veränderung nicht als
chance begreifen sondern als gefahr
sehen und die das beängstigend finden
dass damit kann sie nichts anfangen und
sie ist da sie hat darauf nicht eingehen
wollen und deshalb glaube ich jetzt und
das ist ja sehr stark ein kommunikatives
problem da geht es nicht um so
irgendeine kleine sozialpolitische
maßnahme oder um irgendwas sondern es
geht darum so zu kommunizieren dass die
menschen sich verstanden fühlen und das
jetzt aus ihrer situation heraus noch
mal hin zu bekommen ist extrem die die
sich jetzt an bahnen die
jamaika-koalition es ist das richtige
bündnis um dieses problem anzugehen die
die sich die enttäuscht sind die sich
abgehängt fühlen die als wutbürger aus
welchen motiven auch heraus jetzt
gewählt haben und wütend sind über das
was im land vorfinden ist dass das
bündnis das auf diese enttäuschungen
antworten finden kann
wissen sie herr hoffmann was sie sagen
ist mir zu monarchisch nicht also
gewisser weise steht angela merkel die
bundeskanzlerin einmal für immer und
hört dann doch vielleicht zu und
überlegt sie gibt also dem volk der
nächstens brot wenn es schon keinen
kuchen gibt nein wir sind halt dann doch
noch eine demokratie
die regierungschefin hat eine
wahlschlappe erlitten und das stimmt
mich in den zug sie wird diese kurve
nicht fahren können
und es trifft ja nicht nur angela merkel
wir können jetzt bei cool ihren da
können jetzt wetten anschließen wie
lange schultz parteivorsitzende spd
bleibt wir können jetzt spekulieren wie
lange horst seehofer sich als
ministerpräsident und csu
parteivorsitzende hält ich würde ihr
immer für die kurze frist plädieren und
das finde ich auch völlig in ordnung
dass politiker ausgewechselt werden und
das ist die eigentliche zäsur dass das
jetzt herrschende ich nenne es mal ganz
böse ancien régime es kein regime ist
aber das bild ja dass das da jetzt sich
was ändert und vergessen
ich bin jetzt komme allmählicher
daraufhin in der tat ist es ja nicht nur
die afg und es ist ja auch die fdp die
dieses wieder erleben wieder auferstehen
erlebt hat und so verdienst von lindner
als ganz klare person und jetzt zu
konstruieren wir konstruieren jetzt
wieder eine koalition mit angela merkel
kanzlerin bleiben kann finde ich ein
bisschen komisch denn je nachdem da kann
man ja unterschiedlicher meinung sein
zwischen grünen und fdp ich sehe kaum
schnittmengen
die grünen wollen noch mehr energiewende
die fdp nicht die energie die fdp ist
für einen härteren kurs in der
flüchtlingspolitik die grünen nicht ich
bin es nur ganz stichwortartig die einen
die autoindustrie abschaffen und die
anderen wenn sie viele befördern und so
kann man vielleicht zehn fragen position
auf und deswegen glaube ich nicht das
funktioniert weil entweder werden die
grünen über den tisch gezogen werden sie
von ihren parteimitgliedern verprügelt
und zurecht oder christian lindner lässt
sich über den tisch ziehen oder würden
nicht gewalzt dann wird es das kurze
leben der fdp ein kurzes zweites leben
gewesen sondern kein richtiges wir nur
ein kurzes aufbäumen
also ich sie nicht das was die
alternative funktion das weiß ich nicht
was jetzt die alternative ist jedenfalls
vielleicht eine minderheitsregierung
vielleicht hat sich die spd doch wieder
was ich brauch nicht unbedingt toll
finde
aber zu glauben wir konstruieren da und
jetzt ein bündnis zusammen dass
rechnerisch stimmt politik ist nicht nur
die mehrheit der sitze politik ist auch
überzeugung und gemeinsamkeit in der
sache und die sich nicht zwischen den
beiden opponenten die cdu es natürlich
auf seiten der grünen versucht sie immer
noch zu sein
da kann ich nur sagen wenn christian
lindner da reingeht dann wird er am
spieltisch verlieren was er gerade
gewonnen hat das heißt es ist ja so dass
der bürger aber etliche ja auch erwartet
dass die parteien sich mit dem
wahlergebnis dass der bürger den
parteien bereitet hat das ist ja ein
wesentliches element der demokratie
jetzt auch was
anständiges anfängt und versucht etwas
konstruktives hinzukriegen den menschen
waren glaube ich ihn kaum einer war je
so unklar und unentschlossen
auch weil sie nicht wussten was
eigentlich kommt ich teile die
einschätzung dass eine jamaika-koalition
allerlei praktische schwierigkeiten
bieten wird wir haben ja eine kenia
koalition in magdeburg die verlangt viel
gute nerven von ministerpräsidenten und
die macht die mehrheitspartei noch mal
das video spd und grüne ja irgendwann
also auch eine große zwei kleinere dass
das hauptproblem sehe ich woanders der
wählerwille der wählerwille ist ja in
diesem falle sehr widersprüchlich auf
drei ebenen die erste ebene ist wir
haben eine knappe mehrheit die hat
eigentlich gesagt weiter sucht die große
koalition hat nach wie vor eine mehrheit
bekommen also knapp dran so so sagen im
grunde haben wir gemacht dann haben wir
eine knappe minderheit fast genauso groß
nämlich die menge der kleinen parteien
in sagen wir wollen was anders machen
eben sie auch darauf ab grünen sollen
fdp soll also afd soll alles ändern
zweiter bruch was geändert werden soll
darüber herrscht uneinigkeit wir haben
einen rechtsextremen ausleger wir haben
linke grüne es die pinken ganz andere
richtung das heißt die botschaft was man
ändern soll es auch nicht eindeutig und
die dritte ebene der unentschlossenheit
oder unstetigkeit ist dass wir in den
befragungen wenn wir uns system
vertrauen system loyalität wahrnehmungen
von wirtschaft und gesellschaft angucken
feststellen dass insgesamt der glaube
dass dieses system zuverlässig was
ordnen und ändern kann deutlich
nachgelassen hat das heißt die spd
weiter
gut wie die letzten getreuen die spd den
druck von der basis gespürt auf keinen
fall nochmal in die große koalition zu
gehen so dass sie das gar nicht mehr
beweise haben dass die jubelt als dann
angekündigt wurde wir gehen nicht aber
das modell ich werde kanzler war ja
offenkundig nicht tragbar das heißt es
war von vornherein klar wenn ich diese
partei werde dann einsatz entweder in
der großen koalition oder in der
opposition werde ich dann noch eine
frage ein votum dafür abgegeben was ich
in diesem land tawil ändern der wähler
nicht strategisch gewählt und akzeptiert
vielleicht auch wenn man jetzt nichts
findet an brauchbaren kompromissen an
einem bündnis das lenkrad hält was es
dann wieder zu neuwahlen kommt naja zum
strategisch wählen gehört eine
strategische wahl aber die bot sich bei
dieser bundestagswahl schwer an die
wähler waren wie die demoskopen gezeigt
haben bis kurz vor der wahl sehr
unentschlossen was sie denn tatsächlich
wählen sollten
im grunde war nur klar die cdu verliert
und die afg gewinnt und die spd schmiert
ab die linke hält sich vielleicht die
grünen ja die ist sind besser
rausgegangen als wir gedacht haben der
wähler war auch unentschlossen schauen
sich für diese unentschlossenheit und
unklarheiten war die wahlbeteiligung
relativ hoch mit ghana sicher weil
dadurch die fdlr motiviert zur wahl
gegangen sind ganz wesentlich und in
ostdeutschland die wahl weil es ein
neues politisches angebot gab das früher
fehlte so nach oben geschnellt ist
schauen sie das grundproblem warum es
keiner so wirklich strategische sondern
eine taktische wahl ein flickenteppich
von aushilfen krieg also ein system von
aushilfen ist ein großer mann mal gesagt
hat gewesen ist das grundproblem fängt
damit an dass die spd sich in diesen
langen jahren wo es einen link gemehrt
im bundestag gegeben hat nicht dazu
aufgerafft hat aus der numerisch
möglichen linken mehrheit eine politisch
handlungsfähig zu machen sodass den
wahlbürgern nicht die wahl zwischen
links und rechts geblieben ist sondern
lediglich eine große koalition bei der
nach links der politische raum
versammelt war aber nicht politisch
nutzbar und urbar gemacht worden ist und
nach rechts die union das dogma geflogen
hat sie seien eine partei der mitte und
sonst überhaupt nichts weil sie sonst
nämlich leicht angreifbar wäre
von journalisten von anderen parteien
als rückständig nicht fortschrittlich
und so weiter weil es keine anständige
polarisierung zwischen links und rechts
gegeben hat weil im rechten bereich
sogar wir sagen ähnliche feindschaft
geschworen ist niemals mit der afg auch
nicht im nächsten bundestag auf gar
keinen fall unter keinen vorstellen
waren bedingungen hatte der wähler keine
strategische wahl er musste sein system
von aushilfen greifen und dann haben wir
viele gesagt er dann bestrafen wir die
schwarzen dafür selbst jene die die
fahne hoch halten wollten wie die csu
ist hier in den sog der cdu nach unten
geraten weil sie zwar als löwe gebrüllt
aber es kuscheltier von angela merkel
gelandet ist hätte es diese
polarisierung die hepatitis skizziert
gegeben werde dann die afd weniger gut
weggekommen bei dieser wahl
das ist mir zu spekulativ da muss man
sich doch die einzelnen parteien
anschauen ich glaube auch dass die spd
nicht mehr in eine große koalition gehen
kann weil es ihre wähler sichtbar nicht
wollen
das muss man einfach mal akzeptieren und
bei der spd ist das drama das britische
wissenschaftler ja schön herausarbeiten
das sind weit genug weg dass die
spd-führung wahrscheinlich so etwas
kosmopolitisches hat mindestens in
europa kategorien denkt aber vielleicht
auch sogar global aber ihre wähler
sitzen heute in duisburg oder im
erzgebirge oder ihre früheren wählen und
haben ganz konkrete probleme das
vielleicht die fabrik zu macht oder dass
die rente nicht reicht dass die wohnung
zu teuer ist und so weiter und so fort
und da glaube ich muss die spd sich
wieder neu erfinden vielleicht auch
zurück erfinden ihre wähler in den blick
nehmen und nicht irgendwelche phantasmen
äußern das ist aber das problem der spd
und das der csu ist eben auch so wenn
man etwas fordert und dann noch bis zum
schluss sagt und wir kriegen unsere
obergrenze und die kanzlerin geht ins
kanzlerduell und sagt die obergrenze
gibt es aber gar nicht da war klar dass
die menschen in bayern die csu wählen
sollten die wurden verspottet verhöhnt
ja ich meine das muss man ja auch mal
ist habe ich seehofer muss es jetzt
ausbaden
mitgefangen mitgehangen so ist das leben
und das scheint mir so zu sein
mit zwei kreuzen kann man keine
differenzierte politik abstimmen sondern
da kann man nur
und da sieht man die unterschiedlichkeit
und jetzt kommt's auf politische führung
an
aus dem allgemein jetzt auseinander
fliegen dass wir ja alle konzentriert
haben wieder versuchen eine richtung zu
machen das nennen sie dann würde gefühls
politik oder weiß und was das aber aber
vermutlich glaube ich bräuchte man jetzt
wieder jemanden der das land befrieden
kann wir hatten solche situationen schon
öfters in der bundesrepublik nach der
wiedervereinigung wir hatten es im zuge
der ostverträge als auch das land drohte
auseinander zu fliegen da gab es dann
kanzler die es verstanden haben wieder
eine neue mehrheit zu finden
und jetzt ist die frage schafft dass
angela merkel und da glaube ich mit
ihnen das wird nicht gehen manchmal wenn
die zahlen nicht stimmen braucht man
neue köpfe wenn noch mal die frage
umgang mit der asd im bundestag wie soll
man mit ihr umgehen wie sollen die
anderen parteien wiederum gehen in die
enge treiben ignorieren oder ihnen und
will mäßig erstmal zusammenarbeit
anbieten
ich glaube das allerwichtigste möglichst
unaufgeregt möglichst kühl ohne ich sie
bei der spd jetzt im moment so ein
pathos wachsen als seien wir in der
weimarer republik und sie müssten großen
widerstand leisten gegen die afg ich
glaube das wird völlig nach hinten los
macht oder wie die zeitung ganz das ist
die ganz falsche haltung zur
gelassenheit ist erste politiker pflicht
ich glaube dass das das wirksamste
mittel ist und dann muss man sehen man
muss sehen wie die sich aufstellt wie
sie sich verhält es gibt natürlich
verhaltensweisen die da kann man nicht
schweigen die kann man auch nicht
tolerieren die kann man nicht ignorieren
aber das wird ja gerade die afg
versuchen darauf anzulegen diese
provokation dieses stöckchen hinhalten
und bisher sind ja zuverlässig die
anderen drüber gesprungen muss man
diesen umgang erstmal lernen von anderes
hätte sicher sicher dass natürlich das
ist wir haben keine erfahrung in diesem
umgang im parlament natürlich wird man
da wird wird es auch fehler geben und
man mit lernen er sich die parteien cool
genug also ich meinen die anderen
parteien im bundestag mit der afd so
umzusetzen zugelassen
es ist sehr schwer wie das ist auch
schwer damit umzugehen das werden wir
sehen ich kann das jetzt schwer
voraussehen ich habe eher den eindruck
dass die spd im moment da sehr viel
pathos reinbringt weil sie sich davon
was für hofft und erhofft und dass das
würde ich jetzt so nicht
das glaub ich glaube nicht dass das der
richtige weg ist dass das aber schauen
sie als die grünen im bundestag einzogen
da haben die gestrickt im bundestag was
man entsetzlich fand am bundes bunte
polysun gehabt was man krawatten
zeitalter damals auch furchtbar fanden
hat die babys da drin gestellt ich weiß
nicht was sonnenblumen im hohen haus das
war auch pure provokation da muss
manchmal damit umgehen soll
das ist eine andere kategorie von
provokation als offener rassismus und
schon sagen ja sie haben sich auch
vorhin aufgeregt über das ganze
man muss die regierung sagen das hat
ludger volmer von den grünen gesagt den
kanzler jagen 1994 eine titelgeschichte
in ihrer zeitschrift übrigens da
erinnern sie sich nicht mehr dran also
die provokation ist so neu nicht
es ist ein unterschied ob man pullover
strikt im bundestag oder kinder steht
was ja heute alle tun oder genau da
braucht eine andere frage noch klägliche
in unserem untertitel der sendung heißt
es ja zäsur für deutschland fragezeichen
ändert sich wirklich so viel im land
durch die neue zusammensetzung des
bundestages
ich glaube wir kommen aus dieser
unklarheit
und vielleicht auch den damit
verbundenen lächerlichkeiten nur aus
indem wir uns erstens klar machen ja das
ist eine zäsur nicht so sehr weil die
wahl jetzt ganz viel ändert sondern weil
die spielregeln sich geändert haben und
weil die unbeholfenheit mit der wir auf
diese situation reagieren ausdruck
dieser das unvertrauten mit den neuen
spielregeln es nicht dass die afd drin
ist sondern dass wir vor wirklich ganz
anderen regulation aufgaben unserer
politik und gesellschaft stehen
dass wir diese idee haben wir basteln
weiter und reformieren schritt für
schritt ohne große vision dass wir die
idee haben wir machen uns sauber indem
wir mauern bauen und irgendeiner art
völkische reinheit verteidigen
leitkultur ideen oder ähnliches als gäbe
es da ein substrat des deutschlands und
was wir aber wirklich nicht haben und
was neu passieren dort in den nächsten
jahren und was das parteiensystem auch
noch mal durcheinander wirbeln wird das
ist die frage wie stellen sich alle
parteien vor allem aber die der linken
auf zur frage wie können wir eine
nachhaltige solidarische politik
formulieren die die enttäuschten
modernisierungs für befürchtende oder so
zurückgewinnen kann
die da das gefühl haben wir werden die
so schön heißt ganz normal zäsur ja oder
nein für uns durch dieses wahlergebnis
csu es vielleicht zu hoch gegriffen das
erkennt man im nachhinein immer besser
als als zeitgenosse unter dem
unmittelbaren eindruck von
wahlergebnissen das was auf alle fälle
es sich ereignet hat ist ein erdbeben an
der oberfläche des parteiensystems nicht
die bevölkerung hat einen rechtsruck
gebracht die bevölkerung ist in
auseinandersetzungen großer politik und
mit großem politische entscheidungen
dorthin gegangen wo sie ist aber das
parteiensystem hat eine vergangene
politische meinung und präferenz
verteilung widergespiegelt im alten
bundestag ist die rechte nicht vertreten
gewesen im neuen bundestag ist sie da
und das ist sozusagen das neue denn eine
partei rechts der union hatten wir seit
der gründungsphase der republik nicht
mehr
und dass wir sie haben ist die schuld
der cdu gut dass wir jetzt das
schlusswort bedankte mich dass sie da
waren die zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde das thema neue köpfe neue
chancen
der schwierige aufbruch in berlin
bleiben sie bei phoenix
[Musik]